it took 8 years to reach this moment
this is Dave hoagies 1959 triumph tr3 a
fully restored and ready to race once a
year
California's Laguna Seca racetrack gets
sucked into the past
it's home to the Rolex Monterey
Motorsports Reunion for hundreds of
vintage vehicles Gallup around the 2.2
mile track 1920s Bugattis post-war
Jaguars 1970s can-am racers and more
fighting her first people like Dave hope
we do it because they love cars and cars
are never better than when they're
racing
can a lifelong dream to do some kind of
motorsport whether it's motorcycles or
racing cars but the vintage thing is
wonderful
Steve's dad sold triumphs in the 50s so
he had a connection to the defunct
British company so in 2008 he spent
$3,500 on a 1959 triumph tr3 a after
sitting untouched for more than 30 years
it was in rough shape I saw through all
the dirt and the grease and grime and
the rust and thought well this would be
a good candidate to build a race car
with he stripped down the triumph
knocking away decades of rust and rot
gathered a 2.2 liter street-legal engine
sacrificing power for control like a
reasonable rookie he entered a roll cage
and fire suppression system fixed up the
interior and painted the car in its
original yellow after four and a half
years of daily work the car was ready to
hear it start first I was just wonderful
most people who spend that kind of time
and effort on something don't
immediately risk destroying it nonsense
Dave wanted to race the first race well
I had a couple guys say just finished
the weekend and don't wreck your car
don't piss anybody off and this year he
landed a spot at Laguna Seca it wasn't
the most successful race he was up
against more experienced drivers and
more powerful cars and finished 24th and
but the triumph ran smoothly completed
the half hour race without a mechanical
hitch
minutes after the race Dave was already
talking about ways to improve the car
like a racing engine instead of a
street-legal one he's got now because
let's face it finishing a race is great
but winning is way better
we all want to win a race don't we
that's why we do it